- this regulatory subcommittee on Friday
the 19th of June this subcommittee has
been held to consider an application for
the renewal of a scrap metal dealers Act
2013 mobile collectors license and the
applicant is mr. Andrew browning before
I go on to item 2 on the agenda I just
have a few housekeeping notes to read
out so you can just bear with me I would
like to remind everyone present that
this meeting will be broadcast live to
YouTube and is capable of repeated
viewing the meeting will be recorded
except where there are confidential or
exempt items as in the case of this
meeting if you make a representation to
the meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
recorded by entering this meeting as a
speaker you're also consenting to being
recorded by the council and to the
possible use of those sound recordings
for webcasting and/or training purposes
the council members of the public and
press made the call the film photograph
or broadcast this meeting when the
public and press are Lots lawfully
excluded just a few comments on the
etiquette for a Skype meeting please
ensure that microphones are muted when
you are not speaking that you do not
interrupt other speakers and let them
finish when they are speaking and that
if you are persistently interrupt to the
meeting you may be asked to leave or may
be removed from the meeting additionally
you will be invited to speak and ask
questions by the chair so just please
wait your turn so then on to item two is
the election of the Chairman don't have
a nomination for chair please yes it's
counselor Mabry here I would like to
propose councillor sue carpet ale to be
chairman for this subcommittee hearing I
have great pleasure in second on that
okay Catholic up and down over to you
thank you thank you very much
good morning and welcome to this virtual
meeting of the regulatory subcommittee
can I just mention to anyone observing
that
whilst you might see a number of faces
on the screen these are not members of
the public
they are council officers or
participants who are entitled to be here
that may not be actively involved in the
meeting do we have any apologies for
absence based governance officer none
receive chair
are there any declarations of interest
by councillors cancer beer nope cancel
Maybury no thank you
let's go through some introductions now
please do the participants I'll start
with the subcommittee I am acting as
chairman today and I am counselor sue
Carbondale
I am counselor plea to be a member of
baby district council and Suffolk County
Council and I am counselor Margaret
Mabry a member for beba District Council
and will the officers and attendants
please introduce themselves starting the
legal adviser I'm Nigel tulu legal
advisor to the subcommittee licensing
officer can I hear from the licensing
offices please sorry Chet sorry chair my
mic was muted and licensing officer
Katherine green and the other licensing
officer David Price thank you governance
officer good morning Karen say a
governance officer and our two other
officers please I'm Charlotte bays
planning enforcement officer thank you
and I'm Chris Cornish senior involving
protection officer thank you now can I
ask the applicant to introduce himself
thank you and you are hoping to have
a witness a representative is your
witness present at the moment I think
not all right perhaps when we come to
ask you to speak will perhaps refer to
that matter again right my questions in
the licensing officer have there been
any requests from the parties for
permission to call witnesses
yes chair you can do and the name is
Laura Allen she will be coming in as a
representative / witness for mr.
browning mr. okay and have the parties
indicated they were to present
documentary or other material
yes chair they were disseminated to the
councillors and those of the photos
there were some additional photos that
came through the door so go so correct
yes that's correct yeah right and can I
check with the subcommittee members that
they've seen those photographs yes I
have German counselor Mabry yes I have
you know counselor beer yes I got them
all in front of me as well right thank
you will now move to the hearing itself
and I need to put a motion forward to
the exclusion of the public which I need
to read verbatim on the basis that the
subcommittee considers a public interest
in excluding the public outweighs the
public interest in its deliberation
being held in public it is resolved that
under Section 108 bracket 4 of the Local
Government Act 1972 the public be
excluded from the meeting for item 6 on
the grounds that it involves the likely
disclosure of exempt information as
defined in part 1 of schedule 12 of the
Act I put that motion forward and I
asked for a seconder I am happy to do
that chair councillor Mabry my
colleagues we are all agreed thank you
that's carried chair
you which is now need to pause for the
live-streaming to end
[Music]
you